[Music]
let's go to jessica in phoenix hey
jessica what's going on
hey how's it going outstanding how are
you so
uh you know what i'm doing amazing today
thank you excellent what's up
so
as you guys know maybe i don't know if
you're baseball fans but the world
series is happening and it's braves
versus astros
which is my husband's all-time two
favorite teams and his best friends and
i have the opportunity to potentially
send them to a game
but the financial decision
in that is what i'm trying to figure out
like if it's a good choice or not
because we have money saved up
we have an investment started the only
debt that i have is my student loans
and so i'm just trying to get like a
second opinion of like this may never
happen again the astros versus you know
the brave so is this something worth
saying forget it let's just do it
anyways or what do you guys think
oh you walked right into one so jessica
i was born and raised in houston
i have the astros logo tattooed on my
forehead i just covered up with makeup
just for the show i even took a year off
after the big cheating incident like i
sat down with my yeah he was
nine-year-old son we took a year off
then we talked about redemption and now
we're back
so this is a big moment for me here's
what i will tell you what happened in my
life um a friend of mine is an executive
there with the astros and said i can get
you
discounted tickets and they were for me
uh 300 something dollars i was gonna i
had a whole plan i was gonna take my son
again this is never gonna happen again
i'm gonna i'm gonna here's my plan i was
gonna drive him
to school and then go past the school
and be like dad you missed it and then i
was gonna flash him the tickets we're
going to hop on a plane fly to houston
it's going to be amazing i was going to
state a friend's house i had it all
planned out
and then i saw the cost of the tickets
and then i saw the calls to the flights
and then i thought i started doing the
math on the meals and the this and that
end of this
and so what i'll tell you in my house
i'm not in baby step two anymore
blown past baby step two i don't know
anybody any money and the cost for me
even was not gonna do it this year we're
going to watch it on big tv we're going
to have a blast we'll eat my own food
and we're going to make a big to-do of
it
that's just me and i i don't know what
kind of fan he is he's not a bigger
astros fan than me i promise you
now i i mean i don't know i'm just
assuring you you're
you're wrong george you help with the
money thing here okay jessica i heard
you say a lot of things that were
concerning to me in the very beginning
you said okay you're a bravest fan
that's problem number one now the sports
things aside okay we can make amends on
that part john we cannot but on the
financial side you said we're investing
some and the only thing i just i just
have this little student loan debt i
only have one debt and you were very
quick to kind of brush all the
financials aside and get very excited
and i understand the excitement but you
said are you currently investing right
now is that right
well
yeah so we we have our roth ira set up
and then i have
i sold my house and so we have the money
from the sale of that house set aside
and we've changed our lifestyle
completely so we can continue to save
and so we sold everything we renovated a
fifth wheel and we're living super super
cheaply
okay well you said you said we're on the
baby steps is it okay to buy world
series tickets and in the baby steps we
teach that you only start investing once
you have paid off all of your consumer
debt and you have a fully funded
emergency fund so where are we at on
that side
i have a fully funded emergency fund
and i just have student loans so that's
the debt that you have the cash to pay
off the student loan today
um
all but like five probably about five
thousand of it yeah so what happened
with the sale of the house i thought
this was you made a ton of money off of
this
i didn't make a ton i just made enough
that like i could pay off all of my
student loans and my other debt so i
took care of all the highest interest
yet and now oh boy
jessica we just keep running into first
you're a braves fan and now this
okay hold on
we don't teach you to pay off the
highest interest at first you got to do
the debt snowball so you feel the
progress
so that the next time the braves and the
astros in the world series you're out of
debt and uh you can actually do this and
do it with confidence and not set
yourselves back so how much is left on
the student loan debt
um i have like 50 000.
fifty thousand and how much do you have
in cash in your savings account checking
account
okay and part of that is your fully
funded emergency fund
correct and so you you're doing the the
jessica plan where we go all right we're
gonna get the fully funded emergency
fund but keep the student loan pet
around while we invest in the roth ira
and we're gonna watch a lot of hgtv so
we have a renovated fifth wheel so we
are living okay cool
and doing our own plan here's the deal
jessica i want to send you guys the
world series i wish i could just send it
say it on air we're going to send you
guys we're not doing that but here's
what i can tell you to do i can tell you
congratulations you could have a paid
off student loan today
and you could have five thousand dollars
in a savings account which is going to
get you towards a fully funded emergency
fund and to do all of that we're going
to pause investing if this is going to
take any more than a few months so that
we can speed up this process you've just
been doing a lot you've been doing a lot
of nice good things but we're just doing
them out of order and you haven't been
seeing the progress that you could have
been seeing if you had done all this in
order so on this on the sports side how
much i'm just curious how much is this
whole thing going to cost if you did
this the the uh well game there's
different options but i have also done
the numbers like you guys said and i
would say that if i was gonna send his
best friend with him too it would be
about two thousand dollars
so you have fifty thousand dollars in
student loan debt but you have the
opportunity to send them on a 2 000 trip
and you're living your trailer that you
live in will lose that much of
depreciation over the weekend
but who knows if they'll ever play each
other again like that's where i was at
who knows if we all live on space one
day here's what i do know every single
month you're sending your payment to a
lender and they're stealing money from
you while you have the money sitting in
your bank
so i want this to be a never again
moment where you say never again will my
husband's two favorite teams be in the
world series and we can't afford to do
it hey i actually george i think you're
right here's the thing this is me being
honest with jessica if you had paused
you were investing
sold your home and you were renting a
small house and not bought a fifth wheel
that then you watched a bunch of youtube
clips you have to learn how to like redo
it and be cool and probably post about
it
you would have plenty of cash to
send your husband to the world series
and that's a great gift i love it
i don't think it's a smart financial
movement the memory of paying off this
debt and being debt free forever is
going to outlast
whatever team wins the world series just
saying it right be debt free today watch
the game tomorrow on its big screen this
is the ramsay show